I'd like to begin by thanking Madam
president for the lion for taking the
initiative to organize today's meeting
Russia is systematically weaponizing
food security by deliberately destroying
stocks using famine as a weapon reminds
us of the darkest days of Soviet history
the Kremlin seeks to settle the West
with blame for the food crisis that it
has provoked and orchestrated in order
to pressurize us into lifting sanctions
we cannot give in to Russian blackmail
recent events have proven how precarious
the maritime route is and we must ensure
the efficient functioning of solidarity
lands current EU financial instruments
are not designed to deal with the
specificity of urgency of this situation
hence we welcome the commission's
initiative to provide additional EU
financing mechanisms tailored to the
development of EU UA border
infrastructure we must also remember
that Russia does not disease with its
hostile propaganda the region is most
impacted by the food crisis are being
flooded with false Russian narrative we
Master for continue working on an
efficient implementation of solidarity
Lanes but at the same time double our
efforts to counter Russian
disinformation in the most vulnerable
parts of the world Russia brutally
attacked Ukraine but Russia is also
waging this war against the entire West
against our values against our interests
we need to spread the truth through
traditional and social media outreach to
officials business and The Wider
Community this war affects all of us its
result will determine our future I
believe that Europe still has the
courage to decide its fate